well you're a very very funny comic i i
would like to point out that i've known
you for a very long time yeah you used
to come by a club that i worked in new
york when i was handing out flyers i
worked the same club you did 10 years
before you yeah is that right yeah you
work like the doors at the boston comedy
club oh my god and you always would come
by and this is at the height of
chappelle show fame and you are always
very nice to me and this is a very
surreal moment to have you on the show i
appreciate it i mean it can't be that
surreal we've seen each other a lot
since but i know but i mean
what i thought was going to be received
is like oh thank you and then like a
light bubbling applause was just like
i don't know
you know yeah we eat stuff do you i know
we hang out we're friendly but do you do
you uh remember you used to call me the
kid yeah you go let the kid go next
stuff like that yeah because that's how
people used to talk up to me when i was
a kid yeah like you and truthfully
though you're not that much younger than
me but i just like calling people like
let the kid well you would do it
let the kid
let the kid eat
that type thing but i because i was the
barker the guy with the flyers i would
always go out last and then you would
like be like let the kid go next like
you'd let me go between like you you'd
be you ever get me humiliated as a
barker what do you mean
i got humiliated um
okay you know jerry o'connell
jerry o'connell
he's an actor yes
um right so jared o'connell fat kid from
stand by me yeah and now he's on uh he
was on whatever he's married to rebecca
roman
um
she's always a stamos to me i i know i i
can't i can't lose the statement yeah
even if i know it's over i'm like so me
and jerry o'connell went
yeah
uh me and jerry o'connell went to nyu
together
and uh we were both in like film school
and then i dropped out basically to
focus on handing out flyers
that's kind of i mean i just wanted to
work in a comedy club i just didn't want
to go to school sure so
it was like a friday night i'm hanging
out flyers it's horrible it's like
freezing up and jerry o'connell comes by
with a bunch of like other nyu kids and
uh
and he goes uh hey guys this is neil
uh he used to go to nyu with us he'll be
back real soon oh my god
it was like okay all right just like a
villain in a different like yeah is this
your origin story yeah basically yeah no
it was so like all right yeah that's a
little mean when chappelle became a huge
success did you call him and go how's
college
yeah